hello and welcome to see obtained Nabu
corn or so long whatever okay I already
wanted me now after the last game I'm
going below 2400 with this kind of
completely idiotic game is absolutely
frustrating please give me a win somehow
okay I've got some Dutch defense let's
see what he's going for going for the
stone wall yeah yes quite often measured
install well it's not that bad and here
we see a line that is kind of okay for
black let's see um how to play now in
fact you can sometimes just take on on
b8 plane i therefore i'll do that it's a
bit unconventional but i don't mind some
simple play in maybe equals g5 and then
take on d2 and is fine okay didn't do it
Jessie going for a straight attack here
this creates five min do with some
somewhat old-fashioned way to to play in
the play in the storm well it's okay
it's not since much terrible you can
probably have form yeah well is somewhat
better here but it's not such a big deal
as it looks his Bishop is not great but
sometimes it can go to age five and then
things are not not that clear um I think
I'll try to make this a bit more
difficult
oh it's very uncommon that they play on
the queenside where black is normally
just the weaker side hmm okay yeah maybe
this is not so bad it's got root before
maybe so I still don't quite believe it
don't even consider this move
I just blend at this point it's just
just what it is
yeah probably that kind of game that I
lost before it's just the kind of game
after that you have to probably just
quit and and stop playing because you
just sort them fed up that yeah the
plane really doesn't make any sense
you're just going to play this kind of
nonsense that are played in this game
ok so the worst is over question is
however okay if I take I can take it six
but this is kind of risky yes is check
at the end on the second rank which is
kind of annoying okay I'll take I'll
take this I don't care check Scott roca
III may be accepted the problem here
okay three kings see two maybe
I can have to take this one okay
okay I can take now go age 44 a couple
of passes okay let's do that that looks
and save at least yeah now I kind of
like safe after how this game went at
the game before maybe it's just not
something that you can that you can try
to try to win okay
some key takes I guess so that I can win
a fight I mean it's the draw it I guess
check
check time warning I'm quite sure what
black is trying to do is to try to win
on time check check
check check game draw okay sometimes you
said you should just step stop a session
early i am I was a pretty pretty awful
game tr2 Owens position is just a bit
better for white and to screw it up like
that is really really really miserable I
just blundered upon it just what it is i
blundered this bone Quincy five just
blunders before here should probably
play an or normal move Jim he has to be
quite quite cautious that he's not
lending into some kind of bad ending
like this maybe with Quincy 527 there
are many ways to be a bit better but the
hair played it is just ridiculous yeah I
just I just blundered this full upon I
mean the position is probably good
enough to to not be worse may I should
have taken here actually because this is
not possible yeah I'm yeah I'm winning
okay I tried this and now now is ok
again there's no way a check to be
better here it seems take stakes ok
maybe it takes on age 6 I was going
today immediately the computer wants to
take here and says I'm winning which I'm
bit surprised about
now okay I'm just in time for the a pawn
yeah this is a lot better version than
the game yeah that probably is a win ok
like this and this is what I said it was
playing it safe variation but ok it is
actually check check ok for a second I
saw some check computer evaluation that
oh here I rookie 5 is winning oh nice I
did put a stupid camera I mean there
will be five wins I'll just promote the
upon yeah but I was just thinking okay
why is he continuing to play area I just
wanted one so after the drawing and the
game and then said rookie 5 was still
winning okay a bad game sometimes you
just have to quit a session if you feel
like yeah it's not really going so well
just just quit okay thanks for watching